dans cette exposition c'est en fait une
manière pour moi de dire ce qui est
inadmissible de réagir contre j'allais
dire un drame humain qui m'a
profondément bouleversé depuis 2013
j'avais déjà vu indirectement d'autres
exode d'autres vagues migratoires parce
qu'elles ont eu lieu autour de la guerre
la guerre de 39 45 ou après avec les
boat people
mais là bon je veux dire vraiment on a
eu l'impression qu'il y avait une
accélération une aggravation et donc on
entendait tous les jours des témoignages
donc de noyade de bateau qui chavire
d'épaves et ce qui me
ce qui m'a poussé à réagir c'est à dire
l'indifférence c'est et puis la
sensation d'impuissance de savoir pas
quoi faire pour bon essayer de faire en
sorte que la situation évolue dans une
dans une direction plus humaine donc
c'est un témoignage de ça et j'ai essayé
donc d'apporter ma petite pierre
notamment par rapport aux ong comme sos
méditerranée qui ont fait un boulot
extraordinaire pendant trois ans en
sauvant trente mille personnes en
méditerranée je voulais les aider et
donc cette exposition s'il ya des toiles
qui se vendent 20 100 % donc du prix de
vente sera donc daudet à msf médecins
sans frontières et sos méditerranée
c'est une manière d'agir
en tout cas c'est tel que je le conçois
enfin je veux dire j'ai toujours été
militant donc aux militants politiques
mais aussi engagé dans mes productions
j'ai toujours comment se dépenser qui
laissa devrait prendre du sens et que ce
n'était pas simplement donc on oublie et
que donc quand je fais de la bd ça peut
avoir du sens aussi par rapport à un
contexte particulier et quand je fais de
la peinture en général aussi c'est à
dire que par exemple quand il ya eu le
génocide au rwanda j'avais fait une
exposition qui s'appelait guerre civile
vers six visuels et qui dénonçait le
génocide au rwanda
et là en octobre j'ai fait une autre
exposition la villa chanteclerc qui
s'appelait phantom caraïbes et qui
dénonçait le génocide des premiers
habitants de la caraïbe donc les arts
web des tainos et kalina go alors une
exposition unique mêlant certain nombre
d'objets seule la peinture
de l'audiovisuel des projections sinon
pour tout ça non c'est à dire que en
fait je voulais faire quelque chose qui
me permettre de dire ce que je pensais
par rapport à la vague migratoire mais
pas seulement avec la peinture est
ensuite donc j'ai cherché avec les
installations et les vidéos
ask a créé un ensemble cohérent où les
choses se répondent et renforce mon
propos est comme j'essaye dans la
peinture d'être le plus lisible depuis
direct possible j'essaie de faire la
même chose avec des installations
qu'elle soit compréhensible qu'elle soit
forte pour que l'ensemble amène les gens
à réagir comme dire que leurs
consciences se réveillent par rapport à
la crise migratoire